to refuse the obligations of
international leadership and our duty to
remain the last best hope of Earth for
the sake of some half-baked spurious
nationalism cooked up by people who
would rather find scapegoats than solve
problems is theirs unpatriotic as an
attachment to any other tired dogma of
the past john mccain caught a lot of
people's attention last night with that
remark while accepting the Liberty
middle metal in Philadelphia now it's
been interpreted as a jab at President
Trump and he certainly took it that way
heard what he said yesterday that
Senator McCain yeah well I hear it and
people have to be careful because at
some point I fight back yeah you know
I'm being very nice very very nice but
at some point I fight back and it won't
be pretty
that sure got his art so what does the
senator think about the warning Fox News
caught up with him I don't comment on
what the president says I comment on
what he does
I will say that I have I have faced some
pretty tough adversaries in the past I'm
not interested in confronting the
present I'm interested in working with
the president so Kimberly the heart and
soul of what Senator McCain was
lamenting was that the United States had
occupied a leadership role in the world
for most of the last century
and he sees us as withdrawing in terms
of climate Accords or the Iran deal or
trade deals what do you think I guess
that's what he thinks I'm not sure
exactly in terms of the comments that he
just made but I mean I personally don't
see it that way I don't see it that
we're withdrawing I think we still
maintain a strong leadership position in
the world people know they can count on
the United States and no country is more
generous in terms of times of tragedy or
natural disasters in terms of providing
humanitarian relief around the world
providing military support in the face
of brutal regimes and dictatorships so I
see the United States still standing up
and taking ownership for those
situations as it relates to president
Trump yes he has used you know themes of
patriotism and uniting the country and I
guess if you have an idea about him
that's you know one way or the other you
can kind of like say well this is what
he means by that or this is what I mean
what I think is is that he's trying to
honor his campaign promises he was
elected and he wants to do the things
that he promised the hard-working men
and women and one of those things was
that he wouldn't do bad deals and he
said from the beginning of the campaign
that the Iran deal was a bad deal and he
said that the climate deal was a bad
deal in terms of the large amount of
money that the United States was having
to proffer for it and you know getting
what you know kind of return on so that
I think he's being consistent with what
his campaign message Jesse it looked
like I mean clearly he's saying you know
history has assigned to the ash heaps
this kind of what he called half-baked
nationalism populism well I love John
McCain but he can be a real pain to
Republican presidents I know Dana decree
he was a little bit of a thorn in george
w bush's side I voted against the Bush
tax cuts was very I would say irritating
when it came to waterboarding for
President Bush
the Iraq war was not always very
supportive but he helped you know turn
that around with the surge support
listen he's already sunk Obamacare
repeal it's probably gonna vote against
the Trump tax reform package I do like
what he said though I like how he said
I'm not going to comment on what Trump
says I'm gonna comment on what Trump
does I wish a lot of senators would do
that in court including bob corker
including Senator Graham I think that's
good advice for a lot of Republican
senators you know Dana what struck me
was nationalism especially after the
Austrian elections this past weekend
after what we've seen happen in Germany
after brexit it seems to almost be
global and here you see Senator McCain
almost in a valedictory saying this is
not the way the world should be going
yeah and I guess I think that when you
give a speech like that that Senator
McCain did you almost have to understand
like what's gonna happen in the morning
what are people gonna take away from
this and if it requires further
explanation then you probably should
have put more of that in your speech so
when I interviewed condi rice last week
at the bush center she said she's
concerned about the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse
and it's nationalism populism but two
other isms basically this whole thing
that it's not necessarily just president
Trump's campaign promises it's that
there's a global movement around the
world to to withdraw that might be
better for the American interest when it
comes to President Trump but John McCain
from where he comes from and based on
his experience he sees it differently
and he has never been shy about saying
what he thinks Kennedy DCSS becoming
isolationist under president that was
the other one
isolation isolationism no I would love
interventionist you know if that were
actually the case I would delight in
that deliberately I think of a men but I
think what Senator McCain was saying I
think was more of a direct attack on
Steve Bannon who's coming after
Republican senators like his counterpart
in Arizona Jeff Flake who's very much in
trouble and I think Senator McCain is on
the defensive for some of the people
that he serves with all right one more
thing